hello reject nation it's Greg Albie here
and it's John we have a patreon o patron
plug at the top who does that one of our
reward tiers because we do full a TV
show reactions weekly Q&A is a music
video coverage of our top ones though
whatever video you request we must
definitely do it's always a reaction
maybe one time it wasn't today comes
from a male or female gender neutral 26
year old male or female named lenay
Lynnae is from a small football town in
Texas a huge Marvel comic book fan
really in the sports gets his or her
passion from sports from her or his dad
and no no I got a big going here he she
says that their favor
their favorite sports movie is Remember
the Titans so when I say to you his
strong side I was just thinking of
matching the moon remember the attack on
Titan G not joke I know I have seen he
has just been sometimes strong sighs
strong side left side strong side lifts
from the white guy in the black I start
getting along and racism's conquer just
so behind me now the unraised ism of the
world that I completely forgot about
that foreign culture is great scene
anyway I was trying to make you happy
today Lynnae doesn't want a reaction to
a Marvel or sports video stop Wheel of
Fortune fails this is my time this is my
jam let's do this he doesn't he has a
weird
[Laughter]
you know I never silence magic R and
those nerves when oh poor guy
I just like that it was wind first
[Music]
[Music]
what grumpy doc bashful happy sneaky and
sleepy Oh
Jordan is returned I would like to solve
well please do it properly dopey grumpy
doc bashful happy sneezy and sleepy yeah
just read it
[Music]
check your geography knowledge what
country do you think we're sending you
to Paris France
oh wow literally you know your husband
well-bred streetcar named desire 600 C 1
seen dozens others make it yeah here's a
day
600 okay oh my new somebody solved
somebody solve it 650 there you go a
streetcar named desire funny little game
650 dollars we'll make it a thousand and
although you got the right answer I'd
rather see Kevin's play
[Applause]
- peas - Regis Philbin and Kelly yeah
Kelly Ripa no I'm sorry
we can't accept that it leaves your
turns that are yeah yeah that's why
there's why oh okay yeah no more vowels
okay we just film in there Kelly Ripa
well what do you think there that's
right you know it's good to have him
he's shaking his head no now Shane you
have $3,850 he doesn't get to keep it
guys what a big rubber you might have a
shot man I hope he does baby yeah
there's a beach there like how do you
say that it's again nobody be there's be
okay Colorado Regis Philbin and Kelly
Ripa
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I guess this is the one I think
[Applause]
now will wishes well wishers yeah yeah
group of bill pushers bed man every
chansik i the biggest takeaway is i
didn't realize just how anal they are my
pronunciation on the wheel of fortune
when they say solving the time you have
to answer it when you have to read the
whole thing you have to be able to
pronounce to rewrite those military of a
military man or like pilots i couldn't
quite tell they were yeah though very
servicemen so i'm not gonna give them
crap or not know increased filling kelly
all these are funny they were all funny
man yeah this is a really great list the
thing though is doing something on a
much smaller scale like the movie trivia
showdown I can totally see how you can
brain fart like when the guy couldn't
get magic wand but of course right when
the time was up you got wand yeah I
totally get that because I've had that
experience one too many times when
you're on the spot and there's like
lights and cameras and this is even more
nerve-wracking because you might
actually win a physical money yeah
strippers there's a lot on the line
there's a whole crowd here this is
broadcasted across the nation like this
is a huge ass show it's different than
just earning the respect of the Internet
yeah the nerves are a lot more intense
here I feel sorry for the ones that
solve it and then pronounce it wrong
like mythological hero if you weren't
lucky enough to have been exposed to
Greek mythology you're screwed on I
might have my favorite ones are the ones
that like pill pushers were like I get
it cuz that technically fits there and
you're guessing and you're going big
you're hoping that you can fill in all
those space like that's probably the
whole I would imagine as easy as to fall
in love
yeah you're just desperate to solve it I
feel like the most jaw-dropping one was
when he said and yeah I thought they
would have cut that out of the shower
what's the host name I forget his name
Parris a Pat Robertson I forget but for
him to just feel like no end as a white
male host understand like I'm nervous on
how I react to this right now that was
the the stiffest silent yeah on a TV
show away like you could have heard
anything drop in town that dude
oh man but honestly what is the word
though I would not have guessed
andwe're glam digger clammed it yeah I
probably would have gone with that yeah
or Tigger yeah
clam digger mm-hm that's a real thing
right that's what Tiggers named after
well good oh dude I love these like when
when I went to Colorado and my GF we
watch shows like this and the afternoon
and stuff like this is gonna keep your
brain limber this put me in a fantastic
I mean I was not expecting a laugh as
much Thank You Lynnae I I owe you one
I love you you male female channel put
this together top ten daily daily carson
daly's channel some good stuff you guys
can subscribe to top ten do they
subscribe to the reject nation look that
notification belt please and hey check
us out on patreon or pull a TV show
video so funny